je reçois maintenant le comédien michel
piccoli pour la sortir en salles de
compagne de voyage j'ai regardé un petit
peu votre vie parce que je sais que vous
veniez aujourd'hui dont je regardais un
petit peu comment qui vous étiez en fait
parce que moi je vis avec vous depuis de
longues années puisque je premier film
de vous que j'ai vu c'était le mépris en
63 j'avais 14 ans donc je me suis dit
mais qui sait alors j'ai regardé alors
électivement vos parents étaient étaient
déjà dans fin votre père était
violoniste aux concerts colonne et votre
mère était pianiste elle rêvait d'être
artiste mais la feuille de son propre
père à elle l'avait emmené fia l'avait
amené finalement à donner des leçons de
piano pour survivre et on peut dire
qu'elle souffrait de ça un petit peu en
silence non on lui se fait partie de
cette génération d'enfants de
bourgeoisie très riche qui naissent
étant le douzième de la famille et et
les conditions financières de la famille
sont un moyen pas terrible alors elle
disait qu'elle reste à la maison pour
s'occuper de vous elle vous le reprocher
un petit peu d'être obligé de rester à
la maison à cause de vous non elle me
reprocher pas moi je suis né de mon
frère oui vous êtes las de vote voilà
quand j'avais un frère qui est mort à
l'âge de trois ans et je suis persuadé
d'après les dires de ma mère est
l'histoire de ma mère et mon histoire et
notre histoire à tous les deux que s'il
n'était pas mort elle ne m'aurait pas
conçu away avait donc vous êtes né un
peu comme un remplacement complètement
empressement nous est un problème
enfin un problème ligne un rapport et
votre mère de juliette gréco qui était
votre seconde femme disait en ya deux
ans est une énigme en lui au sujet de
son enfance en parlant de vous des
comptes à régler avec sa mère non ben
oui il ya toujours des comptes à régler
avec ses parents ou avec sa mère bien
sûr j'avais des comptes à régler l'ennui
c'est que je ne sais pas à régler avant
sa mort ah ouais mais ça c'est une forme
de plus de 10 me dit est que j'avais
vis-à-vis d'elle et qu'elle avait
vis-à-vis de moi mais c'est pas pour ça
que c'est un homme et un enfant un peu
sérieux un peu renfermé un peu
rébarbatif non mais silencieux et ne
voulant pas se confier
ne voulant pas se raconter c'est ça j'ai
pas faire de psychanalyse de bistrot
mais c'est intéressant de savoir
l'appliquer voilà de voir comment
pourquoi vous êtes comme ça finalement
vous dites je me suis libéré
quand j'ai fait le métier métier
d'acteur innovant que tous les acteurs
disent quoi un lyonnais qui sent qu'on
rencontre ouais alors si j'étais
courageux et prétentieux j'écris un
livre sur comment je me suis
psychanalyse et à travers les
personnages que j'ai joué paris mais ce
serait pas un livre sur moi c'est un il
est sur moi et sur les personnages que
j'ai joué et sur les auteurs qui ont
écrit ces personnages alors la deuxième
il ya ce côté un peu renfermé et piano
il ya votre côté révolté votre côté
militant alors je me suis dit mais d'où
ça vient j'ai trouvé un épisode de vote
y faisait me dire si ça vient de là à
l'âge de 13 ans c'est donc c'est l'exode
un votre mère vous donne une bicyclette
300 francs et vous envoie comme ça seul
sur la route à l'âge de 13 ans en
corrèze coûté ces heureux d'y aller
d'ailleurs très heureux
il abat pour la première fois quand vous
arrivez voyez pour la première fois un
homme pleurait et vous demandez pourquoi
on vous dit les juifs et là vous vous
prenez ça vous révolte évidemment vous
prenez concept des cils et mais vous
savez quand on a 13 ans 14 ans ou entre
disons entre vin des coteaux des petits
petits ou pas encore bien grand il ya
des événements dans l'existence qui
peuvent marquer bouleversé toute votre
vie mais on ne le découvre qu'après que
longtemps après et c'est vrai que
j'avais 14 ans je venais de faire
l'exode avec tous les gens qui mouraient
qui pleurait etc
et puis mais c'était le plus beau jour
de ma vie c'était mal filmé de clément
j'étais tout seul sur la bicyclette ou
non chlorée moi je me faufilais très
bien j'arrive dans un pays de paix à la
campagne et d'autres réfugiés comme moi
et je vois un vieillard de 40 ans ouais
type lafleur alors après voulait faire
de la résistance mais vos parents se
sont avertis par un boutiquier à qui
vous en parler à vous connaissez des
shows et vous boucle à la maison ça
c'est alors votre seul exploit vous
dites enfin vous dites ça vous dit c'est
d'avoir distribué des photos de de
gaulle lui c'est parce que vous aviez
quand même 7 cette volonté déjà de
militer de résister de militer oui parce
que grâce aux grandes personnes à
quelqu'un je vivais qui était très
accroché au poste de radio à galen g pas
quoi j'ai entendu live comme on dit
l'appel du général dames en arrivant
j'avais 13 ans mais qu'entend l'otan à
monsieur qui soit le général de gaulle
ou tartempion qui vous dit venez
combattre il faut sauver votre pays vous
des héros et bah non ouais bah oui il y
en a qui sont fragiles âgées y en a qui
ont dit non et à la conduite et le
discours de l'autre bah oui mais je
serai entendu disco de l'eau je sais
bien voyez séparer le bon grain de
l'ivraie comme on disait tout à l'heure
alors voulait pas devenir musicien comme
aux parents puis un jour une
distribution de prix et vous jouez labit
merveilleux d'andersen et là vous enfant
timide est enfin heureux et les adultes
se taisent devant vous et là vous dit
peut-être n'ai-je fait du théâtre que
pour ça c'est pour les habitudes ce test
devant moi finalement les gens
m'écoutent
ça a été le déclic c'était le déclic oui
et mais après il ya des évènements
extraordinaires je pourrais vous dire
que maintenant les gens se taisent
encore quand je vise à son métier pas
toujours une fois m'est arrivé une chose
extraordinaire je joue dans un tout
petit théâtre minuscule une pièce de jeu
ne soutient plus le nom de l'auteur et
le spectateur qui était comme ça à
appuyer sur la scène j'aime pas s'il y
avait une rampe très gentiment un objet
part j'avais parlé pendant 10 minutes
tout seul me dit ça doit pas être
marrant dit à ça tous les soirs c'est
terrible mais avec une telle gentillesse
ouais mais que la compassion il
m'encourageait presse on va pas faire
tout autre carrière parce qu'on y sera
encore demain matin mais bon 64 bunuel
j'en à d'une femme de chambre 66 belle
de jour catherine deneuve 67
vous êtes monsieur dame dans les
demoiselles de rochefort vous allez
adorer
benjamin de ville et alors on 69 moi je
m'en souviens à l'époque j'en ai un peu
voulu vous prenez un virage c'est à dire
que vous aviez cette espèce de carrière
très brillante et tout ça et vous faites
dillinger est mort de marco ferreri et
là je dois dire moi je m'en souviens je
vous en ai un peu voulu dire mais
pourquoi ils continuent pas en l'ami
tellement comme ça mais pourquoi il va
faire ces petits films qu'on n'arrive
pas bien à comprendre
oui mais alors je sais comme on a voulu
parce que avant je représente l homme de
quarante voilà de bonne tenue
voilà exacte et rigolent et intelligence
voilà et fit craque je suis passé voilà
vers les sortes de pas de voyous mais de
détraqués c'est ça du thème rock de par
aldo il ya quelques mois mais moi je
n'ai pas envie de faire une carriè avec
une image lisse et lisse immeuble alors
appris la grande bouffe allant 73 ans
l'avait réussi parce que c'était vous
êtes fait huer sur les marches de
l'ancien palais soi-disant
gâcher ma carrière votre mère a pas
voulu voir le film non votre belle mère
n'en parlons pas je crois pas c'est
votre beau-père je crois qu'il était
plutôt au lit ça l'est encore mais je
crois votre belle-mère athées comme
bodmer c'est énorme mon beau père était
en secret c'est un super scandale
effectivement là vous êtes devenu
effectivement vous étiez un artiste
honorables comme vous disiez vous êtes
devenu un peu leur vous a traité à
l'époque de la grande bouffe on vous
traiter de sale [ __ ] de communistes
enfin c'était vraiment bien un ami à moi
dont je tairai le nom mais très
gentilles un moment on a dit que le
bruit courait que j'étais homosexuel à
l'époque encore c'était mal vu
oui heureusement ça a changé oui je le
verse je me suis toujours parler
maintenant comme ie9
oui je sais pas bon on verra et qu'est
ce que voulait dire je ne sais plus qui
a dit mme écoutez c'est normal parce
qu'il fait des choses tellement bizarre
oui c'est normal qu'ils soient où
s'expriment comme si on pouvait faire
des choses bizarres de l'ain dans la vie
que quand on est un homosexuel alors il
ya ya robert chazal qui a fait une bio
de vouchers france empire et ça
s'appelle d'ailleurs ce père michel
piccoli le provocateur donc il ya un
moment au début des 70 cette volonté de
sortir de votre rôle pour pour aller
vers des films plus difficile des films
plus risqués oui j'ai jamais eu envie de
m'installer dans une carrière avec des
rails
brillant tout le temps j'ai envie de
bouger de de découvrir d'essayer
d'autres choses
hockey et ça vous a bien conservée parce
que là je dis pas votre âge vous les
lieux si vous avez vous êtes né en 25
semblait attention 27 décembre 25 ha oui
vous tapez un nom de moi c'est vous a
conservé de choisir le ce côté comme
s'annonce avoue penser oui bien sûr ça
donne une énergie bah oui c'est vital 60
mois ces vandales j'aimerais de tubuai
son cadre
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de winne
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux